[Music]
you're telling me that the king of a
third-world country runs around and I'm
bulletproof catsuit why don't you ask
him yourself because he's right outside
because my king stop it
Black Panther leaves
[Music]
it walks he's coming tonight car wash me
do my hope you ready bro I'm just
getting started
have some fun
showoff
[Music]
I want the weapons my secrets all mine
this your king
this ends today
[Applause]
face your face mother feet
and get tickets now
[Music]
remote driving system activated
wait which side of the road is robust
sick just rocky calm down
let's go
and look at your suit you've been taking
bullets charging it up with
put around the truck
it's certainly been a lot of excitement
about the opportunity to do a standalone
Black Panther based upon the way the
character was set up a civil war civil
wars lost his father coming to this
movie of seeing him actually deal with
the responsibility of becoming the new
king the most technologically advanced
country on the planet a big function of
how wakana works to stand out of the
spotlight stay in the shadows it's my
responsibility to make sure that what
Conda doesn't fall into the hands of a
person like you
the amount of responsibility that he has
as a super girl and who came to meet us
one of the most fun things what happens
now
determines what happens to the rest of
the world the black pencil lives on
February 16
the key
[Music]
what are you talking about look my pen
sir we defeat you 13
one of the things that was so satisfying
about civil war was of course the Black
Panther people came out of that movie
going I want to know more about that
character we want the wow factor but
it's not just stuff blowing up it
definitely is a character piece what
happens now determines what happens to
the rest of the what San Lee and Jack
Kirby created like Panther in the early
60s and he's been a staple of Marvel
Comics 50-plus years he's an interesting
character that is gonna be such a
different thing for the audience on the
screen I couldn't see the Black Panther
living on the side street in New York I
love the idea of a superhero who lives
in Africa he has to look out for an
entire nation that's a responsibility
that the other superheroes don't
commonly have even though he's the head
of a tribe he's a hell of a lot more
than that
as his powers people doing old that will
be a lot of fun
don't please of super sight about when
African Kings also strong enough fast
enough smart enough to do sort of things
that's all about doing it scribble over
there's something very special about him
people can see a superhero on a
different like different world
Black Panther is a world leader that's a
responsibility that other superheroes
don't commonly have that he has to look
out for an entire nation that will only
be the Concord and the dorm aloshy are
women who pledged their lives to the
throne and to the security of the
kingdom my character Okoye is the
general of the armed forces as a whole
Okoye represents the old guard and
tradition while my character Nakia
challenges traditionally you get to
decide what kind of Kings you are going
to me
sukhiya was born to be a warrior she was
born with a warrior spirit I got into a
disagreement made a bit of a mess train
is very very interesting the doora have
a way of fighting that was supposed to
be inspired by moving as one the door
worked together to take down
[Music]
actions there is not your typical film
it's raw it's real
don't please
I have seen gods fly I've seen men build
weapons that I couldn't even imagine
I've seen aliens drop from the sky yeah
but I have never seen anything like this
how much boy you hiding
[Music]
meow
[Music]
my son it is your time
you get to decide what kind of thing you
are going to be
don't freeze I never freeze
[Music]
we
I waited my entire life for this the
world's gonna start over burn it all
what happens now determines what happens
to the rest of the world
stay home
[Music]
what do you doubt about Wakanda textiles
Shepherds cool outfits or front
how much more uniting feelings about
panther but films equally Obama Condit
will see two challahs French people we
ask the answer to you know when he's
sitting on that throne where commas
wounds have been up since its inception
it's the best-kept secret in the world
because they have something that world
once
they have this natural resource that
kind of thrives off of they - technology
it's very sought-after by anybody who's
ever come in contact with this black
panther asked to look out for an entire
nation and also consider that nation's
place and how they affect the rest of
the world to see an African country with
kings and queens and warriors it's so
inspiring it's just an incredible world
to occupy
[Music]
[Music]
fairly something what do you know about
Wakanda is the third world country
textiles Shepherds cool outfits wool
front explores a certain thought called
it El Dorado
they looked for it in South America the
whole time on the only one you seen it
and made that life is changing
[Music]
and the conquerer
you are a good man good heart
his heart for a good left to be 18
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]